all right so I just kicked my shape
layers over from illustrator to After
Effects and
let's go and pre-comp this
call this chaos
PC move all attributes and you don't
have to we're only doing one frame here
but adjust
duration That's Just Gonna Keep the
length of my layers in there
and
let's go and get our first texture in
here
so
I think that is the one that I have
loaded up here you can use any texture
you like it is and here it is
this is the one that I have I believe
this is from
it's either one of my personal textures
that I photographed
um like a kitchen tray or something
metal
and turn it into black and white
or you can search online and find crunch
textures and go that route whatever
suits your needs but black and white is
what we're going to be designing here
and also this is going to be used as a
Luma mat so black and white Works a
little bit better with that
so let's drop it above and do a Luma
inverted mat on our chaos layer so now
you can see
that chaos
I'm not sure why it transparency is
going away when I do that but chaos is
there and it has the texture inside of
it
the next thing that I want to do is
start messing around with some of this
let's get this curves
um
I'll try and use my effects and presets
panel so curves here
and
let's set this up
I'm not sure why that's doing that
that's kind of weird but
I'm going to pull this down pull the
middle up and then pull the back deck
back down and it's just creating a
little bit more beef in the mid-tone
area
thank you
and that works for me so we're making
the highlights brighter but also pulling
them down here a little bit brighter
because this point is in I'm making the
black tones a little bit more on the
gray Side by pulling this up and then
also making the dark Grays darker by
pulling this down and then making all of
the mid-tones a little bit lighter by
pushing this up here
and that is the
tone that we are going to do
for that texture to start
let's go to let's go to create a solid
and call this fractal 01
4K size is fine in any color because we
are going to be loading in
just drop it underneath our chaos and
actually let's solo this
and let's do
um
fractal noise
fire rectal noise so I'm going to be
going to smeary soft linear
contrast of
605
[Music]
a brightness of 26.
a scale of two thousand
look at that perfect and then a
complexity of 10.
so getting a lot more detail in here and
as I said before we're gonna be using
three fractals and sometimes that can
chew up a ton of your RAM in your
computer
so
the other thing I had this set to a
random seed of three but you can see if
the patches the white patches here don't
land in an area that you want you can
change this and they will kind of shift
around
and change up your design
so I had
figured out earlier that three was the
one that I wanted
so let's go
let me drop a new solid in here too
maybe this not being
solid back there
[Music]
yeah I'm not sure why that's doing that
it's really weird
oh well
um well maybe actually let's drop our
texture back there maybe I can do it
that way so this is my second texture
and what I want to do here is just
invert this
texture
and then do a curves
and pull the black points in
[Music]
yeah I don't get why
that is not showing up
it's there but it's not
[Music]
do this
I know why
black we need this to be white
there we go
Luma inverted there we go
and
should that be I think that actually
should be Luma regular Lumina Lumen
inverted
all right so now we're back to square
one here
so fractal one is loaded up and let's do
a camera lens blur
let's type in the right spot
camera lens blur
I'm going to change this to 60.
and this is where we're going to load up
our fractal noise I don't have this
precompt so when you don't have
something like that pre-compt go to
effects and mass and it will load in
whatever effect and or mask is on that
layer
as I said it does chew up a lot of ram
sometimes
so let's set this to octagon which is
going to be a little bit better of a
blur
but that works for me
and now let's add a gaussian blur
to our typography and set this to 15.
and what this is doing is it's going to
if I pull this off see you're getting
these straight edges here and these
really hard edges around the sea set
this to 15. it's going to soften
everything up a little bit now what I
like to do is build this stuff so that
everything's editable and maybe 15 is
too much when I look at it down the road
so the fact that I'm not burning
anything into this it can all be changed
layer later uh really kind of helps
so let's leave it like that for right
now
at 10 and then let's load up a second
fractal map I want to call this fractal
02 let's reset it and what I want to do
is do dynamic
check out this look so fractal type is
dynamic noise type is soft linear
contrast of 407
the brightness is down to a minus 40. so
I'm tightening up the whites here
uh complexity of five
and then
a
250 scale
so making things bigger and then here
I want to mask out if I turn this off
I want to mask out
the center of this chaos word
and then throw a gaussian blur over top
of this let's bring this back so instead
of trying to blur this with the the
complexity like you could pull this down
to three and get some pretty blurry I
like where this is at at five you're
seeing some of this you know the shapes
and stuff in here but I want to expand
this and set this to 30. and what's nice
too is when you do that it's actually
going to blur these edges too
so
instead of trying to mess with
complexity and then your mask feather I
just threw a gaussian blur over top of
everything
and you can turn that layer off let's go
back to our chaos typography
and let's load up a displacement I'm
sorry I keep using this
shortcut there
and I'm going to use a displacement map
and set my layer to fractal O2 same
thing because it's not pre-compt set it
to effects and Max masks and then I want
to set this to 15.
and 20.
and you're going to see
that what that does is it kind of look
at this C here
it kind of makes everything wavy and
distorted
and you can see it in the a shape here
if I turn this on right now
and off
you can see that jump
and it's just going to make things a
little bit more
of that organic feel that maybe water
dripped onto this or you know whatever
it may be that's how we get that effect
all right so the next thing we have to
add is a
glow to the typography now I did build
this with sapphire plugins
so I want to showcase that and then also
how we can get that in After Effects
just using After Effects stuff
so my brightness if you have Sapphire my
brightness is set to
uh one my threshold 2.2 and then my glow
width to six and what this is acting as
is just like a little fill layer but
it's a glow so it's not just Plastering
white over top it's going to look at
this layer
and just thickens it up a little bit
without losing the texture inside and
without losing see how this a right here
watch this Edge
this Edge right here if I turn this off
see how it kind of there's a fall off
here and it just it doesn't look as good
I turned this glow on see how things get
thicker and the fall off is much shorter
so that's what I use the glow for and to
create the same effect
from the after effects glow
let's go down here and let's do a
threshold of 70. it's almost
perfect the way it is but I want to do a
glow intensity of maybe like a 0.6
and then a glow radius of 15.
yeah
so
it's a little bit thicker on the after
effects one
and
[Music]
this doesn't seem that my threshold
no let's keep color channels
uh maybe radius back down to 10.
12 and a glow intensity of
0.4
pretty darn close
so we will leave that and take the
sapphire out
the next thing I want to do is load
my background
nope I loaded my background image
already I want to add
some
adjustment layers so the first one here
is a tint
and that's going to turn everything
black and white and what I'm going to do
now is just kind of mold the whole frame
together so I have my main elements in
here I have my background texture I have
all this stuff kind of working
in its own way and shape and form and
now what I want to do is go and say
okay
let's make this look like it's one piece
of artwork
and we're going to blend everything
together so the first thing let's make
it black and white that's the easiest
thing it ends up being black and white
but
whenever you composite black and white
is your friend
next thing I want to do
and I'm holding down option command y
option control y
to add a new adjustment layer let's add
another glow but this is an overall glow
and
I did use Sapphire glow again
so same thing as before a brightness of
one
a threshold of 0.2 but this time we're
going to go up to a 120. and I can
actually bring this tint up so we keep
this black and white and you can see
what this does is it just kicks a glow
out off the edges here and to do the
same thing with After Effects
one more time just to show you
see how After Effects this is a really
really tight glow and it just doesn't
look very pretty
let's pull this down and maybe go to
like 8.4
let's take the glow radius up to
[Music]
a 140
and a threshold of
something like that
and then I could duplicate that
take my radius way up
my intensity down
and my threshold up maybe
I'm trying not to kick too much into I
want the outside glow to kind of work so
I think that looks pretty good
let's check it with my original one
there's my original one which it's
definitely softer
but this will work too
and maybe
let's go to 200
and let's go to
150. yeah that could work
we'll make it work great
all right
next layer is to add some grain
here
[Music]
I want to set this to Overlay
now I want to add green
and again I did use Sapphire plugins
but I will show you what the
grain could be as well
so this was 0.2 for the amplitude
and the frequency of 800.
and now you can see this grain come in
and this is a key to the whole look I
think
is this green
so it's overlaid over the entire image
but you see when the overlay blending
mode comes in it's now taking that soft
blur that I had and the glow and
throwing in this little green texture
and I think that's so key to get this
blending between the background and the
typography and everything to look like
it's one piece of artwork and you can
see here
it looks like this H is being shredded
apart and the grain is really helping
that when you turn that off it
definitely looks like two pieces there's
typography in here and there's a
background you turn that Grain on set it
to Overlay it looks like it's one piece
so to try and get that to look the same
with After Effects
let's go to AD grain
and let's
preview final output
foreign
do it for me
I want a
800 T is a pretty fast films that should
be a lot of green
and color let's monochromatic this
intensity
maybe do a 1.4
[Music]
okay we're getting there
I'm looking down here and I'm also
looking at this right here that's how
this is blending my softness I want this
to be 0.75
and my size I think I want to go up in
size and maybe try to
close one point
six Maybe
that looks good and intensity let's take
this to 1.8
maybe higher 2.4
foreign
size down to 1.2 you can mess with these
numbers
looks pretty good so you can see the
grain effect though in there
it really kind of helps
sell this effect of being a grunge
typography it's not as I couldn't get as
similar
that's pretty darn close though so
that's how you get the same look as the
sapphire grain that I had
and then there's one more
adjustment layer
here rename this to blur
same thing I used an S blur
which is a sapphire blur
and
the blur amount was set to four
and the offset darks was set to 8.1 I
want to show you why I use Sapphire blur
and again how we can get the same look
so
Sapphire blur has this little offset
dark option here and what that is going
to do is to take your dark tones and
bump them up a little bit into the Grays
so if I set this to a 0.1 see how now
there's nothing that's black in here
it's gray this really is the final key
to the look it just helps sell this
grunge effect so how we can do that with
just after effects
go to a gaussian blur
load this in go to maybe an eight
repeat Edge pixels on this one because
we are
setting this to the entire Edge and
maybe let's go to a 10 and then let's
load up a curves
as well
and drop this in here and pull this up a
little bit like that and then drop this
down
and then set this back on
its line and that should get me pretty
darn close to where I was at
a little too high
there we go
so
gaussian blur keep everything pretty
close let's actually take this back down
to maybe like a six
and then add the Curves in there to
bring our gray tones in versus these
straight black tones and again you can
adjust this to whatever you like
small little adjustments will help over
time
and there you go perfect
all right there actually was one more
layer and this was a sharpen
now you know I just did a blur why am I
going to sharpen this I think it helps
add to the effect of the grunge so the
fact that Grunge was done in a time
period where we still had film cameras
and digital things weren't really
evolved yet
uh they were just starting to come out
so
the fact that
we had analog equipment things looked to
be you know we were watching things on
CRT televisions we were looking at
things on CRT computer screens we just
didn't have the sharpness that we have
today so the fact that I blurred
everything and then make it sharp again
is also helping sell this effect
and you can see now I'm at 100 here
but this is the blur
and I'm putting an unsharp mask amount
of 100 and a radius of five
and kicking some of this sharpness back
in and you're getting this little subtle
like things are sharp but they're not
really sharp effect and
I think that really works well when
you're going for a grunge you can take
this one step further and add a sharpen
two
let's reset this and what I want to do
is go to 100 again
set the radius to 0.5 and the radius is
going to work
tighter around each individual pixel and
then I'm going to set the threshold to
0.2
and if you look what that's going to do
is tighten up
right around the sea here
it's going to tighten up this
turn off
it's it's bare and it's barely visible
but it's just going to tighten up these
edges here a little bit and make things
look a little bit sharper
in a good way because it's imperfectly
Sharp
so that is the whole look now what I did
was I went back and said okay things
aren't looking quite right and how can I
make this even more
you know
grunge-worthy and one of the things that
I looked at was this doesn't waive the
word doesn't wave as much as I would
like it to it's still
kind of on a straight line here so let's
introduce that
and how I did that was went back to my
typography layer
and
let's set this to -10 and 30.
and then let's duplicate and drag this
up let's actually rename this to
and let's rename this displacement map
and what I want to do is go to fractal01
and set this to 15
and see what that does
and there you go
so these two fractals are very important
so this works on the center
of your
typography and it's going to mess with
those letters almost like individually
this one though
is going to mess with your overall look
of things and the fact that now I have a
camera lens blur up here that is working
on this layer
and now I have a displacement map
working on this same fractal layer
it is going to manipulate my typography
with a camera lens blur for the edges
and then also displacing it across the
entire image and I could pull this up
and create more
displacement
I could displace it higher vertically
whatever looks good to you
which that looks pretty cool right there
so this is where you get to experiment
once you have this you know
I'm calling it a rig but once you have
this rig set up you can go then and
animate things and do whatever you want
I almost forgot before we jump into the
next video I want to
show there is one little thing that I
forgot to add here and
in this you have the camera lens blur
right if I turn this off
there's no track matte on this
typography
see the camera lens blur here
it is affecting certain letters and or
certain areas of the letter well when I
put this Luma matte in
the background is clear all the way
through so the one thing you can do is
take your camera lens blur
and copy and paste that into
your
texture and you will see now
that the texture is blurred in the same
areas now it's really really strong so I
believe I pulled this down a little bit
maybe let's try 15 and see what that
does
five
but some scenes depending on what you
need what you have see here see it's a
little bit clearer in the sea over here
and it's clear here in this corner but
it gets blurry and it matches the
blurriness of that fractal shape so just
something to keep an eye out I want to
point that out before we move in to the
animation phase
[Music]
thank you